major developments after that shooting
rampage in California
we'll take great pleasure it's
slaughtering all of you you will finally
see that I am in truth the superior one
the true alpha male
[Music]
this is the face of Pure Evil no not
mine this guy 22 year old Elliot Roger
who had everything a young lad could
want with his dad who was a director at
Hollywood showering him with money and
gifts but the one thing he wanted that
he couldn't get was women and after
spending a few years in college where he
was incapable of getting women to sleep
with him let alone go on a date let
alone even hold hands let alone even get
a phone number from a girl the pent-up
rage from all those sexless years that
he suffered would lead him to do the
most insane act a person can do Elliot
went on a rampage killing six people
injuring 14 others by gunshot stabbing
vehicle running near the campus of the
University of California Santa Barbara
he then killed himself within that he'd
stabbed three men to death in his
apartment one by one on their arrival
three hours late I drove to a sorority
house and after failing to get inside
shot three women outside two of whom had
died he then drove by a deli shot a male
student of death inside and then he
began to drive through Isla Vista
Shooting and wounding several
pedestrians from his car striking
several others with his car exchanging
gunfire with the police after he was
injured at the hip he then crushed his
car into a parked vehicle and he was
found dead inside with a self-infected
gunshot To The Head and the fascinating
bit is he documented his descent into
madness with a series of YouTube videos
bemoaning being a virgin we are gonna
watch some of these videos and react to
them because this is one of the craziest
stories I've ever heard
hey Elliot Roger here
I'm just contemplating about my life and
how unfair it's been lately it's been
unfair for the last eight years ever
since I hit puberty ever since I started
Desiring girls
but they never desired me back it's
interesting that the first thing he
complains about is entering puberty
think about his life before then as a
rich kid with a Hollywood director died
everything he wanted would have been
given to him also bear might he's 22.
still young life has been a living hell
since then
dramatic here I am
taking lonely walks through a park right
now it's spring break
everyone else my age is out having fun
with their friends and their girlfriends
let's have a look at what it would have
been like for other people
[Applause]
spring break is like and this is what it
was like for Elliot Rogers so yeah maybe
he's got a point this is a bit [__]
what type of 22 year old listens to this
sort of Music they should have known he
was a serial killer right then
I'll also panned up for the sunshine bit
there director like it's all mad this
one's titled I'm awesome
I'm getting major Luca magnada Vibes for
all you don't [__] with cats fans out
there
I'm actually surprised girls for what he
was into
you
[Applause]
I couldn't love the 80s didn't he
loves no you just you just have to wait
you'd think he would have listened to
some of the lyrics Do you know what I
mean you're 22. give yourself a bit of
time before you go on a killing spree
get on a dating site or something do
they have one for serial killers I don't
know what would you call that dying to
meet you
[Applause]
[Music]
his Smiles look more like a sort of
awkward sort of spasm
he doesn't actually look happy
[Music]
I suppose that's a smile and then it's
are you looking at me well of course
we're looking at you the [__]
camera's on you
the little rays of the eyebrow was that
a wink I don't know what the [__] we're
doing now that is the most like weird
smile I've ever seen in my life this
next video is called why do girls hate
me so much it's truly a beautiful day
but as I've always said
a beautiful environment is the darkest
hell
if you have to experience it all alone
not for me love my own company and sadly
I've been alone for a very long time the
guy's 22 years old man gangster College
sees people all day every day if there
was anyone who just needed to crack a
massive wank out and be done with it
it's him there are so many beautiful
girls here
but none of them give me a chance and I
don't know why
I don't know why you girls are so
repulsed by me probably the teeth be
honest no it look it may be the hair as
well the hair is definitely needing a
good old trim dress scenting that much
either if we're bit enough we're being
honest I do everything I can
to appear attractive to you
dress nice
I'm sophisticated you're just using
these generalizations that absolutely
mean nothing I have a nice car a BMW now
he's got a point with that one I can't
actually argue because if you've got a
BMW with college it's usually
it's happening for you so yeah that
should tell him more than anything that
is repulsive I'm polite I'm the ultimate
gentleman
and yet you girls
you never give me a chance
I don't know why
you know I
put a lot of effort into dressing nice
these these sunglasses here
were three hundred dollars Giorgio
Armani
so I'll put them up
yeah see we've all met lads who had a
little bit of this in them there was
always that one lad who just could not
[__] fathom why women didn't give a
[__] that was just standing around in
the middle of a road somewhere showing
off his Giorgio Armani sunglasses there
see
hold on oh
he has the car coming up up
sorry what what what's that oh
directions uh yeah go down that turn and
then the net on the third one yeah
Champion what was I doing nothing mate
nothing just doing a bit of
a bit of build watching something like
that see
you have fabulous I work guys in the
rear view mirror like what the [__] is
he doing I feel so invisible as I walk
through my college because none of the
girls there pay attention to me so many
beautiful blonde hair girls walking
around loves the blondes doesn't it your
cascading blonde hair he uses words that
yeah cascading maybe just try and sort
of speak ordinarily mate I mean I'm
trying to give him dating advice here
what the [__] wrong with me the guy's
dead but you know what I mean I'm 22
years old and I've never had a
girlfriend
still a virgin
I've never had the pleasure of having
sex with a girl sleeping with a girl
kissing a girl
I've never even held a girl's hand the
thing is I do understand that this could
[__] some Lads up royally but this level
of self-pity is [__] dangerous that's
just such an injustice because I'm
so magnificent he has that major blind
spot that a lot of psychos do where it's
like okay nobody wants you why not it's
a bias Market if they if they wanted you
they'd have you they'd be all over you
so clearly you are the problem in this
because there's a whole boatload of them
you've just said how many pretty girls
are at your uni none of them want you
sorry if this is triggering any Lads out
there watching sorry guys it's a [__]
just dawned on it none of them want you
yeah and we see this time and time again
in modern society where people just
deliberately don't want to accept that
they are the problem and that pisses me
off because I should be the one with the
girls why
yeah
I mean look at me I'm gorgeous why won't
you give me a chance this is insane they
could have saved someone's life if they
had picked up on this I was doing my
shopping and I see this
this like disgusting looking loser
there's this nastiness within them isn't
it he says these little things like I
was all alone which I always am which
makes me feel so miserable and you
almost sort of think oh is there a bit
of humanity in there somewhere but then
it it's that Darkness within him and he
immediately comes out and says things
like there's this disgusting loser it's
funny because I've seen this clip online
where there was this Hollywood guy
talking about how they Define a hero
from a villain and ironically they all
start with the same problem which is
trauma and it's how they respond to
trauma the the villain Wants Revenge on
the rest of the world for what pain
they've been through whereas the hero
wants to make sure that no one ever go
through that again and then they will
protect the weak from that and it's a
very real thing and we're seeing it with
this kid right now we're turning his
pain into fuel to inflict more pain on
the rest of the world
well he's a loser in my opinion
and he walks in with these two beautiful
blonde girls at his side sounds like a
loser to me yeah yeah the jealousy of
this kid is absolutely palpable it's
like the fuel on the fire it's not just
that he can't have it it's watching
other people have that happiness that's
driving him insane I couldn't believe my
eyes I was so
insulted by that because I should be the
one with the girls all right wise up but
you never give me a chance why is that
if you just give me a chance
well I should know me well I should see
that I am worthy of you oh really why
because I am oh right okay he knows that
he is not what people want and he knows
why he just doesn't want to face it so
he says vague things of I am great I'm
magnificent I'm gorgeous I'm beautiful
not not if it means anything and that's
what sorely driving a mental is because
he understands the truth deep deep down
he just doesn't want to face it that's
why he's doing those videos partly is to
rewrite how he views himself by
portraying this version of him which is
a bit of a character I've got no doubt
that when he's off camera he is a
sobbing little mess who feels utterly
embarrassed and ashamed of who he is but
on here he tries to play it off like the
villain enjoying a nice vanilla latte
thinks he's very interesting
oh yeah
makes me feel all pumped up
those little looks to the camera it is
constantly wondering how is this being
perceived how am I coming across what
will people think when they watch this
ego Maniac I'm doing a lot of thinking
about how sad and unfair my life has
been
all because girls
haven't been attracted to me oh my God
what this is literally a kid who had
everything handed to him from day one
and this is the first time anything's
required a little bit of [__] effort
I've been going through college for two
and a half years now oh God another
[__] sub story about no one wanting
to Shag him at College while other guys
get to enjoy
all the pleasures
of you know sex and socializing and
partying you know I bet he probably
didn't have the balls to approach many
women all of this rage and all of that
he was probably terrified of rejection
which is why he'd rather sit in this
[__] car and moan and complain and
[__] and whine about women not wanting
him instead of getting out there being
sociable risking rejection wear your
heart on your sleeve and be open-hearted
this guy doesn't even have a heart to be
open with he'd rather just focus all on
himself I mean you give a chance to all
these stupid obnoxious guys that I see
you don't give a chance to me
why not
I'm I'm such
a magnificent guy I'm beautiful
can't deny that he's slaying these other
guys why would you want them they're
slobs they're up obnoxious it's like
yeah obnoxious meaning outgoing
confident fun-loving it's not fair
every single day
by the sight of
guys enjoying girls
well I'm all alone imagine you're on a
day and that guy is just staring at you
and your missus is like it's a guy
looking that and you're like they're
nice so it must be enjoying sort of
young love must be most of it should be
happy for us you know what I mean and
this guy's grit and he's [__] she's
Britney's [__] fencing and I'd
[__] love it if they died right now
those beautiful blonde girls should be
walking with me
not those brutes
I deserve them more
why are those horrible men get to
experience the love and affection of
such beautiful Heavenly girls Heavenly
well I've had to rot in loneliness
it's not fair
such an injustice this guy is such a
little whiny [__] I'm just admiring the
view from my father's house right now
this guy literally grew up in privilege
imagine that was his son as well [__]
you know now you're [__] up if this
kid came over here don't you I can hear
some kids playing down there
I'm gonna go and kill them later I wish
I could be a kid again
those were the happy years hey Elliot
Roger here
just sitting in my car right now
enjoying the view of the beach
and my view has been ruined
by this site right here see on about the
bins sitting right there on that bench
yeah he's a young couple oh you wouldn't
like that would he I was enjoying such a
nice view until they came and
sat down and started kissing genuinely
anyone else would go oh this is not nice
oh where was this guy oh for [__] sake
I was perfectly happy until you two came
along and [__] ruined it what is that
guy
get to have such a beautiful girlfriend
he's only see in the back of her head
from [__] 100 meters away but
apparently it's just beautiful to be
fair when you've never even had a woman
hold your hand before most things are
beautiful why can't I experience
something like that right there
well those two
or her no none of them none of them good
for you it's torture for me to watch but
I have to do this I have to film this
I'm now really hoping that these two
start getting overly affectionate I want
him to crack he's in heaven right now
he's probably just sitting like ah just
gone for a little bit of a Wonder maybe
we'll grab some fish and chips
afterwards got home for a shock because
no beautiful girl wants to be my
girlfriend that's true that is true
I hate them this is starting to feel
like the YouTube comment section a bit
he's like I hate them you don't even
know them like how can you hate someone
you don't even really know well
this is my last video
it all has to come to this
tomorrow
it's the day of Retribution
the day in which I will have my revenge
against humanity
against all of you we need more Disney
movies that where people die at the end
and things aren't a happy ending because
too many people grow up with this
expectation this demand of I will have
my happy ending ever I will get the girl
everything will work out things are
going to be perfect and it leads people
have [__] breakdowns when reality
hits and life sucks I don't know why you
girls aren't attracted to me
but I will punish you all for it you're
not going to punish them all for it
actually you're just gonna kill a few
people make a few families absolutely
heartbroken and then everyone else will
go on about their lives as if you never
existed it's an injustice a crime
because
I don't know what you don't see in me
I'm the perfect guy literally
pre-rampage the day before going off and
killing a lot of people I'm the perfect
guy I will punish all of you for it
thank you
his attitude here is if I can't have you
then I will destroy you and you would be
shocked at the older you get the more
you see this kind of attitude in society
men and women where everything is
disposable and I will Slaughter
every single spoiled stuck up blind [__]
I see inside there you will finally see
that I am in truth the superior one
the true alpha male
[Music]
yes Jesus Christ I was just thinking
what would his dad say about this and
actually his dad did an interview about
this how are you every night I go to
sleep
I wake up
and I think of
those young men and young women that
have died
and they were injured and were
terrorized
and my son
did that
my son caused
so much pain
and suffering for so many families he
has to feel a level of responsibility
like anyone who has any regular amount
of interactions with people let alone a
director in Hollywood should have been
able to look at this kid and be like
something is very very wrong here it's
like a reverse nightmare situation when
you go to sleep normally
you have a nightmare and you wake up and
oh everything's okay yeah yeah now I go
to sleep
I might have a nice dream
and then I wake up and then slowly
the truth of what happened
Dawns on me and you know that isn't my
my son was a mass murderer you did not
think
that Elliot was suicidal
or certainly not homicide there's no way
I thought that this boy could you could
flee I mean
this is this is the most unbelievable
thing Barbara what I don't get is we
didn't see this coming at all you had
him in therapy for a decade before this
happened so you knew he wasn't great is
when you have somebody who on the
outside is one thing and on the inside
is something completely different and
you don't see it so it's in multiple
therapists since he was eight years old
and he'd even got his fault to create a
Manifesto which was 107 000 words called
my Twisted Worlds the story of Elliot
Roger and he'd emailed it to his parents
and family and friends and his therapist
apparently he'd frequented online forums
where he and other men posted
misogynistic statements and described
themselves as insults a member of online
subculture based around its members
perceived inability to find a romantic
or sexual partner so basically a place
where him and other guys can talk to
each other and blame women for their
inability to have a relationship Rogers
has also been referenced by other
perpetrators or suspects of several
other mass killings for example Alec
minisian who killed 10 and injured 16
posted on Facebook beforehand the inside
Rebellion has already begun we will
overthrow all of the child and Stacy's
all hail the Supreme gentleman Elliot
Roger
Christ it was later revealed that the
authorities had a chance to prevent the
attack well before the memorable day no
Elliot's mother came across the
uncomfortable video soon after they were
posted while researching her son's name
fearing that he may have been
transported to a nearby hospital the
worried mother hadn't heard from Elliot
in three to four days and was feeling
very uneasy regarding his whereabouts
after finding the alarming content she
immediately contacted mental health
officials who alerted the local
authorities officers then began to look
for Elliott and found him in his
apartment before proceeding to ask about
the videos when conducting the Czech
police surmised Elliott to be an
extremely polite young man that did not
seem to be acting in a concerning manner
the 22-year-old convinced the
authorities that he was completely fine
yep open and shook case today folks
turns out he's just really polite what
about all the stuff he's saying about
how much he hates young girls and how he
wants to have retribution wanted nah
he's absolutely fighting to be honest
with the authors Rachel ever thought
that he might be lying to you [__]
although Elliot talked about his plan
for the day of Retribution in his most
infamous video he left out the horrific
agenda That was supposed to take place
one day before the actual attack
unsurprisingly Elliot stated that he
would torture those he deemed attractive
first he detailed how he would pour
boiling water on their bare skin along
with flaying stripping and cutting their
flesh before removing their heads dumb
this is getting darker by the second to
begin his day of Terror Elliot attacked
and killed 19 year old George Chen a
friend of his roommates he left his body
in the fetal position surrounded by
blood-ridden paper towels in the
apartment bathroom the autopsy report
would identify that George had been
stabbed approximately 94 times wow he
got off on that like that's the type of
[__] where like the Luca magnara guy
when he was stabbing he he just couldn't
stop once he's started he couldn't stop
because there's all this pent up rage
inside these [__] creeps that's why
they keep they can't help themselves
once they start Elliot then took out his
rage on his two roommates 20 year olds
waihan Wong and Chen Hong he attacked
and killed them in one of the bedrooms
leaving their bodies face down with bed
sheets and clothes over them they too
died from multiple stab wounds around 9
15 PM Elliot made his way to the Alpha
Phi house in Ila Vista California where
he planned to kill every girl that
resided in the well-known sorority
luckily for the girls a code was
required to enter fortunately the
sorority sisters were able to dodge the
determined Elliot but others weren't so
lucky authorities discovered Elliot's
Computer resting atop his sheets open
with the words your video has been
uploaded written across the screen
so that was the story of Elliot Rogers
someone who thought he was beautiful
magnificent but really was a deranged
little bastard who was such a selfish
jealous little Pratt that it overwhelmed
him to a point of he wanted to torture
people he wanted to not just take their
lives but make them suffer as much as
humanly possible this was one of the
most mind-blowing stories I've come
across and I do want to cover up more
like this so if there are other guys out
there who have similar backgrounds and
similar videos that we can look at and
analyze I'd love you guys to send me
more because as much of these people are
horrible they are fascinating to talk
about and let me know what you thought
in the comments below about this guy was
a harsh was there a real human in there
somewhere or was that just a devil which
to me would no matter what would never
have been anything other than a killer
it wouldn't have mad if he'd had a
romantic relationships with women
because for me the darkness The Evil
Within him would have come out in any
other way it was always going to and I
just think it's so criminal that no one
twigged at any point long before he did
these horrible things so that they could
have saved these people's lives don't
forget to hit the like button and I will
be back with more crime stories on the
true Geordie YouTube channel so hit that
subscribe button and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]